Narrator: President Trump
has directed $12 billion
into a plan to develop a
coronavirus vaccine in record time.
It's called Operation Warp Speed.
The goal? To have 300 million doses
of a safe, effective
vaccine by January of 2021,
enough to inoculate first responders
and the highest-risk
groups in the country.
- It's risky, it's expensive,
but we'll be saving
massive amounts of time.
We'll be saving years.
- But the pressure to get it out
is forcing pharma companies
to rush through steps.
That's dangerous because it could result
in a product that causes side
effects or just doesn't work.
And the lack of transparency
on how this money is being spent,
and how decisions are being
made, worries some experts.
- Operation Warp Speed is trying
to move as quickly as they
can to develop a vaccine.
And there's always a balance there between
how much you inform the
public along the way
and actually move forward with a program.
- Congress is also concerned,
and recently launched
an investigation into
Operation Warp Speed.
More details about the program
have started to emerge,
but only after key decisions were made.
- And nearly everything about
this effort is unprecedented.
Creating a new vaccine has always been
a long, complicated, and expensive process
that can sometimes take up to a decade.
Trump indicated that the formula
could be finalized as early as October,
which would mean a total
turnaround time of six months.
- It just doesn't show the respect
that should be shown to nature,
which gives it secrets up slowly
and grudgingly and often
with a human price.
- A development for a vaccine,
or any drug that the FDA approves,
typically unfolds in three phases.
In phase one trials,
researchers must prove
that a vaccine formula
is safe and has a low risk of side effects
in a small group of about 10 to 30 people.
In phase two,
that formula is given to a
larger group from 50 to 300.
The test group for the
third and final phase
for any new vaccine typically
includes 10,000 people.
In July, two Operation
Warp Speed companies,
Moderna and Pfizer BioNTech,
entered phase three trials
with 30,000 volunteers.
It's an extraordinarily large size group,
since the goal is to make this vaccine
available to all Americans.
Phase three is crucial
because it shows how a vaccine
will affect the widest cross
section of the population.
- As long as there's this commitment
not to rush the phase
three clinical trials,
I think everything should be fine.
- Officially Operation Warp
Speed isn't skipping steps,
but shortening their length
while funding multiple
simultaneous trials.
And the mystery of Operation Warp Speed
shrouds how it's funded.
Around $12 billion have
already been committed
to six vaccine candidates,
including household pharma brands
like Johnson and Johnson,
Pfizer, and AstraZeneca.
Insider recently learned
that government scientists
winnowed a list of nearly
100 vaccines to just 10.
But the White House has not released
a complete list of companies
that have received funding
or exactly how they're being selected.
Moderna, a lesser known company
before it entered the vaccine race,
has received two rounds of investment,
about $2.5 billion in total.
The startup is the first
Warp Speed finalist
to reach phase three trials.
Their technology platform has never
successfully brought a drug to market.
In case you missed that,
the company leading the vaccine race
has never made an FDA-approved drug.
That's not uncommon for
a new biotech company,
and the federal government supported
Moderna's platform even
before the pandemic.
But the company does have
another potential advantage.
It's connection to the head
of Operation Warp Speed, Moncef Slaoui.
- Moncef Slaoui came over after serving
on the board of Moderna
to run this operation as a contractor.
This has led some people
to have skepticism
around his ties to the industry
and the potential for him to
have conflicts of interest.
- Slaoui, a former pharma executive
and venture capitalist,
stepped down from the board of Moderna,
which has seen stock prices
triple since January.
- And Slaoui has another
close relationship with another
Warp Speed company: his former employer,
GlaxoSmithKline, or GSK.
In July, GSK received
a $2.1 billion grant,
the largest single investment
under the program to date.
As of May, Slaoui owned over $10 million
in shares of the company's stock.
Even with all this money and effort,
there's a chance a
vaccine will never happen.
Other types of coronavirus,
such as MERS and SARS, have
been known for decades.
No vaccine has ever been approved
for use in the US against these strains.
And researchers are still
trying to figure out how people
develop COVID-19 immunity
and how long it lasts.
- But even if scientists
can unlock those secrets,
the plan for how the government
will deliver a vaccine
to hundreds of millions
of Americans remains unclear.
- There are very few
pharmaceutical companies
that have the manufacturing capabilities
and expertise to ramp up
the process so quickly,
and at these massive scales.
- And for Operation Warp Speed,
there's still one major known unknown:
Will people take it?
The last time the federal government
funded a mass immunization
campaign for a new virus,
it did not go according to plan.
In February 1976,
after a US soldier died from
a new strain of swine flu,
the government orchestrated
a $137 million public
immunization campaign.
But the pandemic never came
and research showed that
the swine flu vaccine
may have made some people sick
with a rare autoimmune disorder.
It's an incident that
anti-vaxxers point to
as proof that all vaccines are unsafe
and that the government can't
be trusted to develop them.
It's an opinion that's
amplified by social media.
Recent surveys indicate
that just half of Americans
plan to get a coronavirus vaccine.
Some speculate that
anti-vaccine disinformation
may convince enough people that
it could derail efforts
around a coronavirus vaccine.
- I think most people
are vaccine skeptics,
as they should be.
I think you should be skeptical
of anything you put in your body.
I think it's such a small percentage
of people who are vaccine cynics.
- Some are treating misinformation
as its own kind of infection.
- It's over double the
amount of information online
than it was in December.
In a pandemic, you need
the right information.
And if you look for
information about vaccines
on social media sites or on websites,
the misinformation finds you.
- Search engines are likely
to recommend conspiracy theory videos
about 5G or Bill Gates.
It's much harder to get accurate
science-based information to go viral.
Just look at how quickly masks
became a polarizing issue.
There is concern that
the Trump administration
could attempt to similarly
politicize the vaccine,
setting up an October
surprise announcement
just in time for the
presidential election.
- Can you assure the
American people that politics
and consideration around the election
will not interfere with the science?
- We want to make people better.
We want to send them to the
areas that most need it.
And I think we're going to
have something very soon.
It's going good.
- Science shouldn't be political.
In the case of vaccines,
we should allow this process to proceed
the way that it's proceeded
for the last 70 years,
which is to say, phase one, phase two,
phase three trials, and then licensure.
- Operation Warp Speed is a gamble
with incredibly high stakes:
the reopening of the
economy, the 2020 election,
and the promise of a
return to a new normal.
- There's so much urgency
on this moment to have a vaccine
where if the science doesn't live up
to the political expectations
around these programs,
it's hard to imagine what would happen
if these vaccines just don't work.